[Music]
I'm Stuart brand from the long now
foundation and our speaker tonight and I
go back aways he used to be on the board
of Whole Earth Catalog back when and
point foundation and we were just
swapping stories about 1972 when all
orders put some money into taking a
bunch of poets and Indians and narrow D
Wells and one respectable person which
was Huey to Stockholm for the UN
conference on the human environment
first one and we were all you know doing
parades for whales and making an
encampment with a hog farm outside of
town where they wouldn't let the hippies
into Stockholm and we had a kind of a
sideshow called life for him
well Huey was there he was I guess
Western Regional Director of the Nature
Conservancy then and while we were
fussing around being sort of protesting
on the side he got into the big tent and
played with the big dogs he did that I
was just hearing by waiting until the
guards went opposite directions and then
he sprinted and ov over a hedge and
broke into the building and knew some of
the heavy weights inside who immediately
got him past the barrier that the next
administration had put up for people
like him
that's fairly typical Huey Johnson get
into where the action is and make stuff
happen it happened again I was working
with the brown administration and a
couple years in he wanted a fresh
secretary of resources
California Resources Agency is pretty
much like the Department of the Interior
tenure is big and certainly is powerful
in this very green state and so I got to
make the phone call to Huey Johnson to
invite him not would he mind coming to
Sacramento and serving his state as
Secretary of resources and he modestly
accepted and California was permanently
changed by that
I'm particularly interested in hearing
what he has to say tonight because
well most of my green friends has been
going kind of in the activist direction
much as we did in Stockholm putting on a
show over here doing parades and trying
to do profound thoughts and stuff he's
over with the power guys
money is the laws are the institutions
are where the really long-term stuff is
there's a book of his outside called
green plans blueprint for a sustainable
earth
in a version that is what he's talking
about tonight Huey Johnson thank you my
subject tonight is the culmination of
years of obsession it seemed to me that
there had to be a good way or good ways
of managing the environment for the good
of the earth and humanity and eventually
after they threw the rascals out of
office and Sacramento at that time I
wandered around the world looking for
what must be a better way and I actually
found it it's interesting if we're
looking at a 10,000 year clock along now
I think to look back to because
particularly an environment there is a
chance that things get repeated and
history is that way and the question
about China and Rome ancient
civilizations the question about China
is why were there a number of dynasties
instead of one the answer is they would
have a dynasty booming along just fine
until population grew beyond the
capability of the lands food to feed it
and then things fell apart internally
Rome same thing one of the six reasons
that Rome declined was an environmental
one they did a poor job of irrigating
their wheat belt in North Africa if salt
builds up they couldn't grow a weed
anymore couldn't feed that mobs bred in
Rome they were upset and that soon
became the end of it
and if you look through history we're
going to appreciate that in this country
we ended up in a treasure trove of
resources and we haven't taken much care
of them we observed the
decline and had some challenges and
problems with it the West is littered
with ghost towns that were boot mining
boom towns and many other examples of
decline clear-cut forests from the
eastern seaboard right through to the
west and about the time of the change of
the century Teddy Roosevelt came along
and he was a great visionary he had
rather than going into public school he
had kind of gone on private outings and
his family took him to North Africa and
he was introduced to this Sahara as a
young student and began to interest him
and is a naturalist and he really
started a important direction it's a
philosophy and they went along with him
up to that point John Muir started the
Sierra Club inspired a generation and
many generations hence and we then enter
the important era of trying to manage
things beginning we'll say in the early
1900's Roosevelt put together the first
meeting in history of all the states
governors it was about the subject of
Natural Resources then things continued
to progress and I can remember when we
were in Sacramento air quality wasn't
really that big an issue we knew there
was smog but we were busy doing other
things worrying about energy and water
and what-have-you and all of a sudden
you couldn't see and now we realized
that is an unhealthy condition mercury
alone is responsible for 600,000 babies
a year in the United States being
affected before birth and we are facing
a condition where China's building a new
coal plant every week said and where the
fumes from that drift across the Pacific
and come on into California and so the
problems continue to mount California
exists we are a desert it exists because
we've built dams and all the Sierra
canyons and the water is allowed to
trickle out water that is from the
winter snows usually and that could
become a problem the mercury point this
is Minamata the first example of the
disease in this case a village in Japan
getting its water from a stream that was
being polluted up upstream by mercury
poisoning and then we had the important
awareness factor of being able to look
back at the earth we think Stuart brand
for that he understood the importance of
doing it and worked hard and
demonstrated and got it done and that
was very important for our thinking and
then we progress and there are a couple
of points I want to make for you that
you probably aren't aware of one is a
very valuable asset you have they are
the public lands every citizen in this
country has more than two acres
equivalent in the public lands by extent
of being a citizen and those lands often
have very valuable assets on them
forests water grazing lands timber
mining well you don't know that because
the people are enjoying the profit don't
want you to know that and there where if
a grazing parcel of public lands were a
private parcel you would pay fifteen to
twenty five dollars for what's called an
animal unit that's what it'll grass and
land it takes for one steer to walk
around and eat and grow and the public
lands charge the fellows who have that
they've been Heretic most of them
dollar 35 and so the loss is a taxpayers
problem the other problems recently
there was an interesting expose in the
press the Department of Interior office
it manages oil you saw that they were
caught with drug practices and
interoffice sexual practices with oil
industry executives and one thing or
another
and a bunch of them retired in a hurry
but there is a very valuable asset and
it's something you should be aware of
it's a light and political issue
somebody had a wake up and jar our
politicians one problem we have is the
politicians benefit they get when the
guy gets a gift from the public of 14
dollars worth of free grazing because
the only pays a dollar 30 he's pretty
smart and he hires lobbyists and they
donate part of that back to the
political people and little is said
Diane runs fat and happy on that source
their Western Governors the guys that
are the crudest and roughest in Congress
run happily on that source another point
of a historic transition was the
Abramoff expose recently this for the
first time really gave us a clear
contemporary look at the problems
involved with America's resources he
particularly worked the Department of
Interior the mining lands of timber
lands and what-have-you and there he is
embracing our good president and then we
come to the important factor of water
again California our existence hinges on
water when Stewart and I were in
Sacramento in the 70s we had a drought
and got to be pretty sweaty we ran a
pipe over the richmond Bay Bridge so
Marin would have some more water and
we'd sit all day while every
the city the mayor's would come in and
the AG interests would come in and they
would grouse away at each other and in
this case eighty percent of California's
water is claimed by agricultural
interests the balance is claimed by
cities this was a portion back just to
the turn of the 19th 1900s and it was
done in a way that there were two uses
for all time it's going to be
agriculture or development environment
didn't get anything that's why one of
the key reasons the salmon collapsed
recently in the ocean here because they
have to come in go up the streams you
have to have water that's cool enough
and deep enough to spawn recently we had
a remarkable experience for my point of
view a investigative reporter Mike Terre
did this story and it is immensely
important important enough that we have
a award that we would like to give him I
hope he's here I haven't met him as yet
it's like you're in the audience
one of the examples of the integrity the
prize comes with a thousand dollar check
but he declined to check saying that he
would feel he would risk his reporting
integrity I guess okay there's that
would you mind saying a few words for
you'll get a copy of his of the story
it's very impressive oh thank you i I
didn't know I was going to be saying
anything I guess I would say that thanks
first of all second of all I think that
the water is the story in California
it's it's it drives the that drives how
California exists its economy and its
natural resources and it's in limited
supply and there is a a it's it's become
a zero-sum game and it is being fought
over in the next year or two I think a
lot of big decisions are going to be
made little that will I think shape the
future of California it's it's an
economy and it's a ecosystems thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much well you'll have a
copy of that article and it's in depth
and it's wonderful it's the first time
I've ever seen a successful story like
that the Southern California water
interests dominate politics in
California in my view and you'll see why
this is
one of the communities that's survive
and thrive by the water that's pumped
600 miles south from where we gather it
up here the important message that I
have been obsessed about all these years
looking for a better way to do it kind
of had a break when a UN commission
chaired by a woman a Dutch I mean she
was Norwegian a doctor and a commission
to find a better way of managing
resources going around the world and
they did a successful job I think
the message is very much the same some
of the problems you have as a state
trying to retain quality of its life for
all of us is things like time you can
clearly see the dilemma of the time and
office compared to the impact the
picture that was on the screen when you
arrived was Lake Tahoe and the lowering
of Lake Tahoe during a drought period
that we have right now this better way
of doing things called a green plan I
found by going to Norway and I was
really dazzled by what they had in the
way of resource management policies and
so on and they said no no no you you're
too easily impressed you've got to go to
the Netherlands that's where they're
doing it right the after that period
this model they have so-called green
plan has been involved in a number of
other countries New Zealand particularly
has a green plan there's is a bit
different in it they're an agricultural
nation and they export clean green
products Mexico has a Mexico City has a
green plan we took a bunch of Mexican
political officials to Holland a few
years ago and that has resulted their
European Union has adopted the
Netherlands example hired the Dutch
specialists who designed that program
and it is doing very well there and the
EU as a result is now setting standards
for the world on Environment the
European Union establishes its laws and
regulations for the 500,000 customers
that make up the EU and then they say
and the rest
who wants to sell stuff here has to
conform to our rules and thus mr. Bush
and the boys run into trouble and even
Silicon Valley was warned a few years
ago that they the European Union was not
going to let a lot of electronic
equipment into the EU because it had
heavy metals that were allowed not
allowed there and the result was Apple
Computer had to withdraw some of his
products that was selling in Europe for
instance and this is a important example
and it's tragic in another way the US
was the leader in the world ethically
and technically and we faded in the
background Singapore is a wonderful
place to visit in part because of their
green plan they have probably the best
green plan going but they traffic has
took no traffic jams everything's
controlled and they have a quality of
life that is superior to our own at the
present time they're the main thing
green plan does is manage all the parts
of the environment we traditionally have
managed our environment as though we
were managing one part of our watch my
watch has 82 parts but if I only do one
part a year at some point that watch is
going to stop running what I want that
watch to keep time I don't really care
about whether one part or another is
cleaned and you have to keep all the
parts working to keep a watch keeping
time well we've learned the hard way you
have to do the same thing on managing
the environment and these are terms and
themes that the Dutch system used and/or
uses it's interesting because it also is
managing complexity I've never seen a
government able to tackle complexity and
make it function successfully and define
it and put it together in ways that
other people can pick up and copy and
they want you to do that because
if global war climate change gets worse
they've taken a third of their landscape
from the sea and they could have water
over the walls of their dikes and be wet
again so they're very cooperative
another interesting factor in their
approach is that they sit down business
and government went in a room business
approached government in this case the
it all started when the Queen gave a
speech in 1988 she's allowed one speech
a year not written by the bureaucracy
the Dutch royalty it turns out like all
European royalty learned their lesson
from Napoleon and they don't let the
royalty get away with saying a heck of a
lot independently and in this case the
Queen said it's Christmas Eve and I'm
setting aside my normal speech where I
give Susan awards for taking care of the
tulip bulbs and Joan award for keeping
the finger in the dike and we're going
to deal with a very serious problem our
scientific community has come together
they've done a thorough study of Dutch
environmental quality standards we have
the best in the world except there's one
problem they're not good enough and
there's a very real chance that we will
have no Dutch great-grandchildren it was
a pretty sour message for Christmas Eve
and the next week people started meeting
and amid those was a desmos big business
leaders and they sat down and said you
know hey we ought to do something and
thought that time they got an invitation
from an Eastern European country newly
freed from the Soviet bloc and that new
free country wanted to know how to run
their affairs in free enterprise system
they looked at so if somebody come in
and tell them how to how to run it and
they looked at Germany now they'd want
to be elected even want to be like the
US and so on and but the Dutch know
there you go they're successful
economically children are taken care of
good health care housing everything
let's be like the Dutch so they sent a
jet and business leaders got out and
went back to this place and he landed
they got off and they looked around and
son of a gun
everything was polluted streams were
dead children playing in them air
quality was terrible the Soviets had had
their heavy industry located there and
paid no attention environmental quality
and they were supposed to stay a week or
something that night in their hotel they
had dinner Nate said gentlemen this is
what we thought we wanted no regulations
you know we can't help these people we
really really can't we better go home
and think this out and they did they
told the host to next stage year we're
sorry we just can't help you we've got
to go home they came home and they sat
down together and then they went to
government and said we're gonna propose
the most radical move imaginable for us
we want to propose cooperating for years
they had been filing lawsuits way we do
and and they were smart enough to say so
let's we know how to take care of it if
you set the standards but it's going to
require some negotiating on our often
backward battles over the years and one
side of a regulation or another and the
nonprofit's were used to sit outside a
pack of snarling dogs bitching saying
that they weren't doing good enough
demanding perfection of what was going
on inside and when they progressed they
would pass out whatever their decision
was and that NGOs would look at it and
send out a media release and commanding
it or criticizing and whatever and the
business interest press government to be
darn sure they gave grants to the NGOs
environmental groups so they would be
vigorous from there and that was
critical to the success of the whole
plan because the environmental movement
was able to threaten those who wanted to
leave any in business representatives
and they would really being pressure on
those who didn't want to go in the first
place
and that really is what turned things
around
one of the things then in managing
complexity is to admit as with a watch
you've got many parts we in the West
tend to manage one thing at a time this
year we manage water next year we'll
manage air then maybe we'll get around
to energy in the meantime water policy
starts falling apart behind us and so on
and the problem we discover is that if
you're talking about water policy you
have to talk about energy policy because
in order to run the pumps to send the
water 600 miles down Southern California
over a mountain range to boot you have
to burn some fuel to get the electricity
and that pollutes the air and we always
have ignored the connections there and
the connections of course are far
greater than that
in their defining complexity in simple
terms we're gonna run through a few
slides to demonstrate that they have a
social contract they call it where they
understand generally what they're trying
to achieve and the public is behind it
politically and willing to fund it they
have to have each generation be
responsible for recovery during that
their time and not just passing it on
they started out the very first thing
they did was list these eight points and
they became the premise of what they
were going to build on an interesting
one is no waste export that means
nothing leaves Holland that's
manufactured there if you've got bricks
you don't send them to some poor country
in Africa you get rid of them in Holland
another thing they did was being honest
about the impact of their programs and
their efforts and they went right out to
the global when they were doing any of
their planning these are some of the
challenges that they really started
focusing on realizing they probably
could have an effect on actually
and these were points that they focused
to manage of all the problems they had
they decided they had to correct these
first as they started out down the road
of total recovery in 25 years was a goal
it at every level salmon back in the
Rhine transportation problems taking
care of health problems taking care of
the works and they're doing it there but
in their 20th year now squandering is
wasting resources you know putting an
extra layer of tin on a tin can when you
get to get by with one they would they
would believe that you don't need to use
the quantity of resources that we use in
society and they've been very effective
at that it's interesting there's a side
story with that I go back the reason
this worked another reason work pretty
well was luck but they had a Minister of
Environment who was the head executive
in this large consulting firm called
McKinsey American consulting firm well
it's all over the world the guy in
Holland was conservative and grumpy and
he said damn government he said I'm
gonna run for office and he ran for all
of us the next thing he knew he was the
Minister of Environment and he didn't
know anything about the subject and some
young people and in these Dutch agencies
had been dreaming for a chance to carry
out an idea they had so they came to him
they said mr. minister here's our idea
and we think if you'll follow it Holland
will be an example for the world and
they had 82 things to be managed that
would return environmental quality in
Holland and this guy who's an expert
made a million dollars a year or better
as a salary working for them said well
tell you what he said if I were advising
General Motors I wouldn't let them have
more than five points because a human
mind can't handle all the intricacies of
interrelationships of more than about a
few points
managed something gets too big he said
so you guys go back and you come in with
five and I'll do it
and they came back and they they stuck
on eight he finally but he said where in
hell did you get those 82 points he said
all the guys in the US EPA that's what
they're following interesting
experiments that have been very
successful for them the idea of green
taxes they get about 15 percent of their
tax take each year now from Green taxes
and it's really neat to visit there
because these things are prominent the
kind of bottom line for them they came
up with this term several years ago they
normally accelerometer Osen the problems
from industrialization pollution and
what-have-you growing with it and what
they decided they could do was to have
the economy grow but the problems to
drop and that's this design the you can
see I think the that's the economic
growths and this is solid waste they've
taken taken care of solid waste it's no
longer irrelevant problems are them for
instance and they put a lot of beauty
and philosophy into their stuff and in
order to get things going they went to
the right place they went to the US and
brought to us public relations firms
over to Holland to put together a
campaign for them to get this thing sold
and maintained by the public and another
thing they do is print everything in
English and they're much like the
Germans there so they've been assigned
the task of building a better Mercedes
in the Germans and they do a book on the
tires and they do a book on the steering
mechanism and a book on the seats
you go face down your soup real quick
trying to keep up with all the printed
stuff that comes out from them I've
tried diligently
and it's a challenge
I actually went facedown in my soup once
I was over there and I there was a
wonderful guy from Wisconsin names
Gaylord Nelson he was a senator and
Gaylord had invited me to be his guest
at some award banquet where he was
getting an award and it just happened
that I could take a plane from Amsterdam
to Bill walkie or wherever I did and she
I was in that they had cocktails
beforehand he was very handy with the
pouring drinks and playing poker that's
how I got to know him and playing poker
all night in Wisconsin woods and so
anyway i tottered to my place at the
speaker's table and damn I was tired I
kept just biting my lip trying to stay
awake the next thing I knew I was asleep
and he was very generous and joking
about it a long time to come
another fascinating success New Zealand
just tore up a lot of their laws and
restructured their government around
managing resources and in that case they
had a long debate in their Parliament
and finally at about midnight they've
got no place after many days and one
grumpy old senator said damn it I've had
it this is all I'm putting time I'm
putting in on this subject said we've
ruined our year and he said you guys are
just trying to put together a grab bag
for all the social problems in New
Zealand and I'm not gonna buy it and
they said well what would you buy
senator and he said what you wanted to
do is manage this stuff more effectively
from what you've been talking about they
said yeah he said well this calls a
management action we'll load it as such
and they did and it really is successful
and has turned around their country's
approach to managing resources and
enhancing the quality of their citizens
lives which is much of what government
ought to be about each of these topics
of course has a chapter I have a book
out there and it's one of many that's
available on the subject they practice
good management again they delegated
from their central government definition
which they're going to do right down to
local and City Council's and those are
working very well
we've had a problem
but that problem is about to end thank
goodness and at least mr. Obama's team
has this particular collection of things
and that they're studying it we hope
then suddenly about the time I started
to relax a little bit here came climate
change and last summer an example of
that we had one a thousand forest fires
all happening in one day we couldn't
even get enough people together to fight
them and it you have to be in a forest
fire to appreciate the terror of it I
one roll ahead there in Sacramento was
responsible for four fires or floods or
something rather and if the state and
federal governments were going to work
together in a problem I had to sign off
on it and one day they'd call me and
there was fires happening in Southern
California play and picked me up at the
airport and in Marin and Lewistown and
they put us in a fire truck and went
roaring down the highway that was closed
because of the fire and we these guys
were very macho firefighters they were
showing off of course but damn the
flames were belching over the road 100
feet in the air it was just like any
imagined hell and we came to a spot they
in order to stop and looked off the edge
and there Donna Canyon was the wind with
creating a blowtorch effect a wall of
fire as high as the ceiling it's just
screaming and there were 300 houses down
there that were being torched by that
and boy I'll tell you it's that kind of
thing and floods the same but nature
bats last and we tend to get carried
away sometimes with our ability to
control things but as we learned in New
Orleans and other places we haven't
quite gotten there yet and right now
California faces this problem of drought
and water problems and we have the worst
water laws of any state in the nation
and they're purposely kept that way by
those guys in Southern California that
managed to that article that Mike wrote
notes that they won water district the
current water district longtime problem
water district in my view managed to
take off with a hundred million dollars
of a water bond issue and that's what
articles about and what is research is
about first time that goes on a lot but
that's the first time I know of that
it's ever been documented and still
isn't being paid much attention to
well we get to a good part California
had the luck of having a governor and a
legislature that cared a woman named
Fran Pavley was an Assemblywoman now
running for the Senate and she carried
this bill a be 32 and this a be 32 is as
good as anything going on in Europe or
any place in the world if it were passed
and operated is it could be it's a very
important moment for this thing because
October gets your last view today was a
deadline for commenting on air quality
as part of it the administration skipped
today as deadline but the special
interests are maneuvering like mad
trying to weaken it and I think it's the
most important legislation this passed
in a century and it a lot of it will if
it's carried out will enhance the
quality of your lives and if you have
any grandchildren guarantee they'll have
a place to live too these things take
years to put together because there's so
many in rooted interests that you have
to bring around work out and so on a day
took five years in the Dutch case about
four years New Zealand's case of ardent
work on those issues to get them in
definable shape
that 12% I was ad came pretty much from
a Jerry Brown administration's days in
Sacramento that was a goal we had in a
while so there are a lot of factors
involved with this a b32 and we're going
to actually hand you a piece of paper
with an address to be in touch with to
comment on this idea and why what you
think about it if you think it's
important
normally we've only passed bills to deal
with one resource a hundred bills
several thousand bills were introduced
every year in Sacramento for instance
and for really the first time we've
woven them together in a comprehensive
very important recovery plan for the
vitality of the state but as you might
expect there are some flaws and one that
you might write about if you go all
through this thing there's just sick as
heck and fine print and whatever you get
to the point you realize well where's
water water is ignored in the thing it
has one point it says well we should
charge $50 to hook up water fee to hook
up to a new building that's it so one
thing you could do is say for God's sake
governor let's shape up and correct your
your water problems and include you
can't really have environmental
management if you're not managing your
water in a desert state the only place
where the state and mascot is found we
have an office here at Fort Mason the
resource renewal Institute and be glad
to answer any questions in the future
that you might have and an additional
point I would add exciting to me for
years I felt when I grew up as a child
grew up in
northern Michigan and great thing to do
is go ice fishing so I bugged a friend
of mine over the years who has a travel
agency saying I'd like to go ice fishing
on Lake Baikal in Siberia and he agreed
and I'm gonna lead a trip in March if
anybody wants to go just got their news
thank you
[Applause]
Huy
another title for this talk that I saw
you used to some of your mailing lists
was basically long term green planning
and one of your diagrams showed the
difference between the time of
environmental impacts and the time that
officeholders yeah government typically
problem are in place and you word love
to get a little bit of the these are all
Californians here and a lot of
Californians will watch the video a
little bit of sense of the continuity
you had what six years as secretary
resources yeah tell me a little bit
about the stuff that you and Jerry Brown
and everybody in the administration will
put in place and then what happened to
that and sort of what's the trend line
over time of the kind of stuff that you
guys did then well we started out with a
what might today be called a primitive
form of green plan and I put together a
hundred year plan for the future of
California first of all and went to the
Republican Party and said this is what I
want to do I want to start managing
these resources together comprehensively
and doing a better job we've done in the
past and they laughed at me and said you
know you're so controversial there's no
way you'll even get this saying print it
up Republicans will block it and I said
all right this in fact will bet you a
dinner you won't be able to get it
accepted and so all right and we backed
off and I went and sat there and used
with my friends and we thought oh we got
to get some industrial leaders and
somebody knew somebody that knew
somebody inside IBM at a high level and
before long I was sitting down with a
guy in charge IBM in the West I told him
I wanted to do he said it makes sense
good for the economy good for the
employees I said can I use your lobbyist
he said help yourself
then I went to the Bank of America and
got the same response
I saw the Pacific Railroad and several
others and then when I went back I
flashed my role
gambler and those guys said Oh God so we
got it passed and we're able to get I
think it was a hundred and twenty
million a year from offshore oil
revenues to run it and much of it is
still in place and still running there
are tricks to the trade of keeping
things in government there's a term
putting tracks in stone and if you get a
bureaucracy that's sold on an idea and
they love it they provide some
employment and it makes them feel good
don't even let that thing disappear and
they people will try to make it as
appear but they've suddenly somebody
will lose a letter
it's got to be signed that date I never
got there and nobody knows anything so a
lot of things continue do you have
examples of that from what happened
Magian came in after Jerry Brown yeah
moved on then what happened how did the
things you baked in actually persist
through that a quick story about
Deukmejian I on the public land issue
wanted to sue the federal government
because they had been dishonest in
rigging statistics on wilderness
legislation in California there were
they were going to turn loose all our
wild lands let it be logged and took
Meijin and I weren't the best of friends
at that time and he would pass me in a
hall he might say hello you son of a
[ __ ] and I would say well you bastard
whoever it was it's pretty intense
so he wasn't friendly and I learned that
I had to get him to sign the complaint
the Attorney General the state has to
sign the complaint if you're going to
sue the federal government hollow world
they're gonna do that
was his attitude well I better be known
I want to have it done and one of his
secretaries was an ardent
environmentalist and she studied him
well and said well he comes in the
morning before he reads a paper and he
signs about he's got a stack he signs
about twelve things he reads and then he
gets hurried and
distracted and he just signs them all
we soon we won so that was an example of
the system if you've got it in your side
it really works pretty well play hard
play dirty lesson right that's a little
bit dependent on the personality you
know how do you I mean you mentioned
getting the the staffs of the
departments engage do these things what
else you do to manage this kind of kind
of there's no hope if if everything is
switches when the pendulum goes back and
forth yeah that's part of how a you know
a two-party democracy works because back
and forth that's right
and it acts like an eraser so how do you
overcome that
well it doesn't act like an eraser
because it is in place with a British
parliamentary system on through ours and
others once they've debated intensely in
the legislative process that somehow or
other has gotten to be law and it is on
the books and it's functioning it's
pretty hard you can come in and you can
spend some time and you can erase some
things I mean I got in the over the
first day I announced I was going to
oppose nuclear energy boy that bought
down the house and I just went looking
for guys that were nuclear engineers
have been planted by the industry in
their state agencies and I got him fired
[Laughter]
and they probably never got back to you
right on them actually got one question
here without a name on it again at
California politics what is your opinion
of California Proposition 10 that
requires more use of renewable energy by
utility companies
I think anything like that that we can
do we should do and the utilities in
California have really been pretty good
we passed some early legislation that
required that they improve over what
they had in the past and so over a
period of years they've ranked well up
on top of utilities and states the
nation
and so anything we can do to keep them
improving we should and they'll always
oppose new ballot issues they'll hire
lobbyists and try and block everything
that is proposed but once it's in place
as long as it's what's called a level
playing field and if everybody has to
live by that rule they don't mind
they'll [ __ ] about it but they don't
mind and thing you've got to do is be
darn sure what the ballot issues are
prop 7s coming on now what's his name
the guy from Texas pick yeah he's
bankrolling that which will benefit his
business and his friends and it'll be
dressed up but that one we ought to be
but a lot of this stuff is that one watt
to be what I'm not doing or do not doing
okay but ten you like yeah all right
here's a nice systemic question from
David Wechsler where's white blur right
here the examples of governments with
green plans that you gave to have
relatively small populations that maybe
the European Union which is just getting
started so what do we know about
complexity of natural systems that might
shed light on what we will have to do to
manage them at the larger scale
especially global scale given climate
change how these things scale I mean you
know you had devolution there in New
Zealand
you know they've worked it down to the
local cities and Regents and so on but
we're talking big it's bigger than
Calvary done well if you look at don't
see the EU as small it's twice the size
of the u.s. 500,000 citizens they're
buying things and demanding pardon five
hundred million I'm sorry all right
thank you for taking your five hundred
million okay and that's a huge market
and they've got 27 nations and they are
an example of phenomenon to me of having
been able to work out their fiscal
policies so they can share a euro and
they have lived on wars
for centuries where they would disagree
over little things constantly well
rather than have in third world war
they've turned the EU into a working
successful example of managing
complexity and when you get out in the
world I'm not I don't really have an
answer since we haven't gotten there yet
I would certainly try and put together a
new agency the world agency the UN has
had some wonderful successes and they're
limited but if you're facing certain
disasters say on climate change I am
somewhat optimistic that we will come
together and deal with it what what
would be a model of this kind of global
entity I was just WTO or what besides
the UN what the hell're is there to say
people do it like that only green yeah I
haven't struggled with that question
okay someone here please
we're going to have a conference on
October 16th the day before the Bioneers
conference it's part of the Bioneers
conference in Marin and we're bringing
over some of the original thinkers who
put together the Dutch green plan and
the New Zealand green plan and there
will be there answering questions and
speaking on the 16th all day or thinking
about national things these days because
we have a a presidential election going
on so Kevin Kelly's question is adhering
to your principle of keeping the
challenges few what one function would
do the most good on the US national
scale about instead 82 and instead of
you do five maybe but actually start
with one
well I were the most important one would
be water management you can get you can
get by with half the energy were using
and but when water starts disappearing
civilizations have historically declined
and we really face that and we were
close to reverse migration and the last
drought when Stuart and I were in
Sacramento it was a sweaty time papers
didn't talk about it but it was there we
now face another potential problem like
that and we're not ready for it our laws
are played with and manipulated by
particularly these traditional water
interests so you want to change the
pricing structure or what I would change
certainly the pricing structure the
health aspects the process for
delivering and
and all the technical processes that
would consume energy cleaning water
moving water that would allow it to be
reused water really isn't it ultimately
in that shorter supply if we apply some
of the tactics that we can apply to make
it reusable instead of just using it
once then pouring it in the ocean we put
enough water in the ocean every day in
Los Angeles to irrigate 125,000 acres so
could easily be used and is being used
in progressive places another
presidential campaign question you're a
fisherman and a hunter and the world
wants to know what is moose hunting
really like well I saw her with a
caribou down and that's very close to
shooting a Chevrolet truck in a used
truck plot there isn't much to it and
it's kind of embarrassing I did it once
and that was a delicious caribou but I'm
not going to do it again
it's a not much sport or ever involved
with a moose what do you do once you've
killed them yeah well the moose always
wins because they're so big you can't
turn them over you've got to clean
whatever you get and I'm an ardent elk
hunter and I've noticed as I aged a year
ago another fella and I both has a good
fortune or misfortune to get an elk at
the same time and they were close
together we walked up to the elk and she
was we couldn't even we were wrestling
I'm trying to get them over so you start
cleaning them and then you've got to do
all kinds of things with them to get
them skinned and ready to cut up and so
on at boy you had a several long day's
work by the time you do that and then
moose are far worse and the worst thing
you can do is have to take it out on
your back which I've done with elk and
you take it sixty pounds at a time and
it's usually uphill in the snow and not
much for a city boy I hear the word in
Alaska is never shoot a moose more than
a mile away from the road not even that
far away
here's a question from anonymous
wherever you are anonymous
once upon a time it was rumored that mr.
Johnson mr. brand had a falling out over
nuclear power do strong egos provide
leadership and or internal operation I
would say you always should be able to
disagree with your friends and I have a
habit of being very intense in my
disagreements and they ranged far and
wide and I can't say I've everybody lost
a friend permanently yet so I probably
should have and we're still friends as
you can tell
oh sorry I like nuclear power for green
reasons and Huey just likes nuclear
power for green reasons I got a well
concerned about because of the years in
Sacramento and happened to meet some
Russian scientists who were over here
campaigning after Chernobyl against our
ever tackling nuclear and I got to know
them well and they invited me to run
over to Moscow twice and spoke to the
Russian Academy of Sciences about it
debated some and I've only been the
Russian scientists were wonderfully
courageous men who had looked at Soviets
in the eye and said no goddammit we
don't want anymore
and they risk their lives and careers
and they published several hundred
papers now opposing nuclear and reasons
why they've the other groups have been
studying downwind of Chernobyl and
everything is polluted you can't burn
the firewood you can't grow vegetables
it's really a mess and human factors
health-wise and otherwise biggest
wildlife area is of course around
Chernobyl yeah same thing as the DMZ and
in Korea whatever you know there's
actually you know who really loves
radiation for this kind of purpose is
Jim Lovelock he says look if you want to
protect the forest just to release some
radiation and there are people all going
out that's right animals don't give a
damn you'll be good idea
I changed my directions a question from
Carol DiBenedetto for you right here do
you think the fort
can't be trillion large amount of money
google plan may help keep the us back on
track toward an integrated green plan
have you tracking on what google.org is
up to I read about it in the paper I
don't know anybody in Google and I would
love to and everybody to get a nice
grant from them to go tearing off after
one thing or another but so would
everybody else and what happens when
money comes in to do your operation
we're a small operation with an office
here and we would set up a project hire
some employees define what should be
done on that particular project and
started out we often look for ideas the
examples of that there's a certain
amount of money made a certain thing
happen yeah there's a thing called the
Grand Canyon trust and I sawed it up
here in greens over lunch and determined
that we would do well to use the Grand
Canyon as a flagship for the world's
parks that that would be important to do
and so we put an organization together
from this office and established it I
was on the board a year and then I
resigned
the organization has gone on to do that
work and they've got offices now in
Washington Utah Arizona and they're
doing very well so that's an example of
our attempt to take an idea put it in an
institutional form how much this kind of
stuff works well city level I mean
Portland San Francisco or taking a lot
of miles for being green municipalities
is that true and how can they be better
I again would turn toward European EU
examples where Copenhagen and Amsterdam
and The Hague and many other places
really are remarkable in their progress
and their concern and their management
of Environmental Quality and the a city
can be managed very well
maybe easier than some of the expansive
landscapes that we try to manage why
it's comprehensive and you've got more
people to deal with the problem people
who pick up trash people to debate and
understand and support or disagree with
politicians and to bring pressure on the
on the powers that be to bring about
change I think San Francisco seems to do
that pretty well with a mayor and it's
vegetable gardens and solar programs
what's the ideal interaction between the
city and the region or the city and the
countries of the rural the rural Oregon
thing how's that work out best the ones
I know about I think Portland Oregon has
a regional form of government and it
really works it's effective and so they
have Central City and then all the
outlying cities and they have policies
in place they're continually improving
them and it's every city planners
dreamed to have regional city approaches
that's the only one I'm aware of in the
u.s. it works that way
never Larry Peterson from Sacramento
Bakley he was he's a teacher city
planning in Florida and he there's one
big watershed
damn straight we're back there what can
we expect from a new administration in
2009 basically do two things you're
probably tracking on this what do you
think will happen assuming say Obama
wins and then going forward assuming
they'll do whatever they come in with
and then what should happen well the
first thing that happens is the special
interests will be first in line they
will be there manipulating and
pressuring and being damn sure their
base is covered if they can and the
appointments to these federal agencies
likely Department of Interior
that oversees this two acres at each of
you own these guys will want to make
sure that doesn't change they want to
get the gold free out of the ground
which they do now don't pay a royalty
the Mining Act is passed in something
like 1867 and it's never been changed
and you get a free ride if you mind gold
on the public land and they'll try to
keep things like that in place they'll
try to keep water management in place as
laws that are revenue issues they're a
way that the government could pay its
bills better for it revised all laughing
it sure would but right now those guys
are the special interests are smart
enough and the election laws are so sad
as regards funding that they get all
this water freeze I mentioned the 100
million that current water district is
Mike wrote about and you can bet a good
hunk of that goes back into politicians
campaigns so the rules don't change so
they can keep doing things like that
they've been doing it for a hundred
years they're not gonna change if they
can help it so that those forces really
start moving in on the Democratic Party
the Republican Party whoever is in
office and contributions are bundled and
given probably the most challenging
environmental law change we have is
campaign finance reform because you can
the key to political problem is a
committee in Congress controls
legislation it's going to be introduced
say there's seven member majority we'll
all you have to do is buy four or five
of those guys so that you can never get
a majority against your issue if you're
an idle company so the legislation never
gets out of the committee it can be
introduced still and so the ease with
which one can affect politicians with
contributions is a snap parliamentary
system in in Europe or these other
places by comparison I like because they
limit the time you're going to run
something like eight weeks and they
limit the funding and there's no ability
there to control committees by bribing
anybody and it's healthier in that
regard
where you involved a couple years ago
and sort of getting the Green Party
going in this country I attempted to and
kind of withdrew from it it it became
mmm as often happens in politics if you
have an idea and it starts to look like
it's successful we all have some dream
in our pocket we'd like to see enacted
his working policy for the nation if we
see a wagon coming down the road that's
got making headway damn we will paint
Irish green and jump on and the Green
Party soon had so many attachments and
layers and social dreams that obviously
wasn't gonna go anyplace
so I remember a Ralph Nader became the
Green Party president he's still running
what was your opinion of that
well that was courageous and he knew he
wasn't gonna win and I am glad he did
and of course I'm happy he did because
of a resulting effect and mr. gore was
that one of them were way too evil added
gore not to win because I want Gore to
win but I mean this was I recall there
was a lot of dissent because he peeled
off enough of the liberal vote mm-hmm
that the close election went against the
Democrats no as I remember you said that
you when he became the candidate you
called Ralph Nader and decided he didn't
know how to spell the word environment
and then called the Green Party guys and
said you were resigning is that how you
remember I don't remember that clearly
but something like that he has to be
diplomatic no really that's more
questions go ahead and stand up with one
if you got it
which one
remind me great go ahead what do you
think of the drill baby drill
yeah well I obviously opposed it for a
number of reasons not the least of which
it would be ten years before you had a
drop of oil out of the process and the
other is we could right now not be
importing foreign oil if we just enacted
what jerry brown's administration
started when he was there of energy
conservation as a first priority and the
oil interests are so damn powerful that
they can just manipulate and change
things yes sir
good others here that question basically
is you Garrett Grenier is who ran for
governor a while back
it was surprised that he was focusing on
water and wonders if maybe a carbon tax
that would be more of the essence right
well I think carbon tax per se ERDs to
just discussion about carbon so much is
a panacea it's a part of the problem and
we've made it the big things because
fossil fuel interests and others can
make a profit from it and it doesn't
really make that much sense cap and
trade cap and tirade in my view I think
that there should be a green tax and the
Dutch example say a little bit of how
the green tax works well it's in the use
of term green tax and it up and apply it
in different ways they might put a an
extra dump fee that would help cover the
cost of something else an extra fee on
fuel at the pump years ago anybody's
been in Europe and filled a car I
remember a little Volkswagen the doggone
gas tank was 75 dollars 10 years ago and
that's 75 dollars to build a new bicycle
lanes the public was delighted with it
and fact and one of our colleagues on
point board named Bruce
Cates Bruce Gates right was over there
and a huge sailboat
invited me a fierce guest I were gonna
holla and I did and he had a couple of
bicycles and we went whizzing off across
high lunch it was a Holland it was a
wonderful experience that time being his
guest about mass transit review all four
of the fast train to LA I'm sure for a
fast train to LA I'm in favor of it the
first attempt was to go down the coast
and we're gonna go from state park to
state park and
I oppose that vigorously and they now
we're gonna go over the hill the other
way down the valley I think that's a
good thing I really love trains I'm sure
you do we all do
being a bullet train and Japan is a
nifty experience questioning back there
well I really was passionately for it
when I got a college and still am
however it just was outmaneuvered
politically it didn't have any champions
who knew what they were doing and soon
it was swept aside by the latest gym
exercises or more mathematics or
whatever it is in the popularity contest
that represents curriculum planning and
education in the u.s. you get a sense
that I remember this your relation with
a point board and when we were in
Stockholm and so on you were also the
kind of harsh realist amongst all these
idealistic greenies that I was hanging
out with and basically telling the
ideologue to grow up and get realistic
and practical and pragmatic and get down
and dirty with the politics and make
stuff happen is that still your advice I
would say probably it was a bit brash he
was known in our group as the spell good
for good for good no I would it is very
important to have passionate people
making their case in a free society for
whatever they believe in and that I
didn't have that but I have some
photographs of the Dutch program with
people demonstrating you know kids
marching down the street with flags and
so on demanding that more be done in
fact a quick story about that I happen
to be over there once and there was to
be the first meeting of a huge
new youth group in Holland environmental
group what had happened is a couple of
recent college graduates are held will
this go out and sign up all the
nonprofit groups in Holland and call it
an organization and then we'll have a
conference and we'll terrify the
government so they did and the big
University they had the largest
auditorium in Holland and
standing-room-only and they're on stage
were these two guys students who started
to sing and it was big enough that they
had 30 350 thousand members they waved
around and on stage with him was a head
Minister of Finance for the government
of Holland and Hoonah suit invest and
sweating and another one of their
highest officials and these kids marched
up and down and looked at them and
browbeat them and said you know you guys
have driven us in the hole Holland is in
debt and now you want to retire and be
fat and happy and leave it up to us to
pay off all the damages you've created
if we don't like that and we want you to
get serious you're running government
now we want you to clean the damn
environment up we want you to start
spending five billion more than you're
spending as of Monday morning or we're
gonna vote you guys out of office and
these guys were we don't have that kind
of authority you know we can but the
result was they compromised and that
youth group got an official recognition
that nations get so that the minister
gets to sit down once a month with a
prime minister to talk about
relationships now were you saying
earlier that the Dutch government gives
money to these NGOs yeah to be such a
pain in the ass yeah and they'll sue the
government too with that money
they play really well the Dutch you're
neat that way you know they've got good
drug laws the earliest child labor laws
things that we you can walk up and down
the streets the alleys and the pot shops
are kind of fun how is that not
corrupting and
I'm a greeny and I'm getting how much of
the money of my organization will be
coming from the government it's tempting
to be very corrupting okay well how much
money I would say probably if you're
active in that saying a third okay and
there's every reason that whoever's
handling the money flies come to money
the way they do manure and you can bet
that there will be problems with that
but it isn't going to be a permanent
condition and it has worked to the point
that those environmentalists didn't have
to get a job someplace else
they sat outside those doors and they
sent out their press releases and they
cheered or moaned depending and help
make that Dutch plan of success and the
business leaders who were inside said of
all the things that made their program
go it was a threat of the
environmentalists outside the door that
kept them all working inside does that
thing would have disintegrated in
seconds a number of times and been there
so I think I've seen the importance of
citizens voice dissent a lot since I
made whatever statement that was back
but the way you tell a story the the
change came when the businesspeople
decided a change needed to happen and
they basically then you had the triad of
government NGOs and business point in
the same direction rather than at each
other yeah see a little more about how
that happens how that might happen here
or is it already happening here and what
does one help happen further what's the
structure of that one it was it happened
as I mentioned because of the experience
the Queen speech and going over to the
Eastern Bloc countries which we got the
Queen we need a queen yeah that's it
well Hillary
that's right and a lot of things are
large US firms are doing business in
Europe they understand clearly what's
happening there and they work well with
it they come back here they just act
like they know rules and it's our fault
as citizens that we let them get away
with that if an administration was in
office that wasn't vulnerable to big
contributions they would come to the
table themselves and say hey let's in
fact they will anyway with the EU
setting world environmental standards
the US has to get in shape and conform
to that kind of behavior in order to go
out and be successful competing in the
world if you make something and you sent
it over to EU and the u.s. I'm sorry
it's got pollutants in it take it back
even that's happening in our beef
industry punches so much hormones and
our b50 EU won't let it be bought in
over there this has been going on for
years some beef gets into it very little
and we just stubbornly say well hell
with it
you're gonna buy our beef or else or
else what oh we're not selling our beef
and so they are getting to be a very
strong international voice and their
behavior is such that other countries
are following suit and we have fallen
behind thinking we might not have to
were used to being the tough guy in the
neighborhood we're not any longer
how about Asia the Singapore a leader in
that respect or of just a interesting
local city-state doing something amusing
but irrelevant they're kind of an enigma
all right they're city-state I went over
there probably 40 years ago my first
time through and boy it was dangerous it
was a lot of change in 40 years yeah
that's right and I remember one thing I
grabbed my billfold pickpocket in an
alley and I had it on a chain and I
ended up wrestling him in the
getting my billfold back well now you
could lay on a park bench in Singapore
with your billfold on your chest take a
nap and nobody touch it and that's
happened you've read in the paper about
how severe their laws can be they had a
their first Prime Minister was a really
a green guy and he got in office and he
said well I wanted to do certain things
a B and C and he said to one of his
aides wants you to be in charge of
cleaning up rivers and the hotel were
Hemingway and the boys is still there
it's a beautiful beautiful hotel now
then the ball what ball paper was
peeling off the walls and the beer was a
50 cents or something
now beer is ten dollars and it's marble
and he told this guy tell you what son I
wanted that River cleaned up and if you
clean it up I'm gonna give you a gold
medal and the guy cleaned it up he
didn't say what he wasn't gonna do but
this guy was pretty tough and this he's
had and that was Lee Kuan Yew procedure
right all that happened and you know we
had Haiti right next to this the
Dominican Republic story is told in
Jared Diamond's collapse book and he's
gone steadily downhill and there was a
dictator in Republic who for reasons
unknown was a greenie and when you fly
over the island now one half is green
and the other half isn't because this
dictator said it's gonna be green get
used to it
so it's that what it takes is it takes a
the benign dictator here well I think it
takes a leader leadership comes in many
forms
and ideally comes in a free society with
an election and everybody's inspired and
the new leader says guys us get together
and girls and let's build a bridge to
the future
where's Lee Kuan Yew had been termed out
after eight years yeah a long time yeah
I mean he was he was in office for dead
girls and you're talking about these
things that take decades and I know some
mayors that have turned cities around
like Charleston they were there for
decades
so his term limits sort of go against
what you're talking about I think so I'm
not happy with term limits it makes it
far easier for the special interests to
manipulate the person who's only going
to be in office for years and the person
gets out in the water committee and all
of a sudden the lobbyist comes in and
has been there for 20 years he said son
I can give you all the information gonna
need no we'll just do this thing right
and that's what happens the lobbyist is
there for 24 years they come in with a
new election and the new guy on the
committee he keeps doing this and the
system gets worse okay so we're gonna
see a playoff I mean that the major sort
of climate impact besides ours which is
huge is coming from China increasingly
and from India increasingly and China is
aware of Singapore and many important
ways in India is a somewhat chaotic
democracy but has also got a lot of
things going for it
how do those two play out over 20 years
it's a lot to worry about last year I
was a chaired a United Nations
environmental conference in Beijing and
on my panel was the Minister of
Environment and population for the
nation of China and there was another
member was from the Indian Parliament
and got one of the Gandhi family and
some others and we had a great afternoon
and I said to the Chinese fellow I
understand that you have taken one third
of your agricultural lands out of
production I think that's kind of stupid
that was for cities and expansion or
what so they could build more factories
and create more jobs to manufacture more
gadgets and India done the same and I
said cheese you know you guys have a
history of trauma when you have droughts
and the guy the Gobi Desert is only a
couple hundred miles from Beijing and
right now and we're
so much dust blows off it that in
downtown Tokyo or in his Korean cities
you can't see people have to wear masks
coming off the growing deserts and I
said do you think that's pretty serious
yeah but he said the forces for the
economy economics are so powerful in
this country said I have very little
impact trying to do things right
they said I tell you one thing I've
closed down 17 factories in the last six
weeks because they were violating our
pollution laws and they're shut down I
want to tell you he said I understand in
your country if you even try to shut
down a factory
they'll just hire attorneys and keep
right on going they're right I had to
laugh and say yes now India loves to
shut down factories they just shut down
the top cheapest car in the world I saw
that and I heard him discuss that the in
India the same problem occurs they have
the subsistence level living in the
villages has been successful they had to
use a bucket and a rope to get their
water out of the village well all of a
sudden now they can afford electric
pumps and so and they got some subsidies
for those pumps yeah government usually
does that worst thing ever gonna do is
give subsidies who did that so now the
larger landowners are happily pumping
water with electric pumps and the water
tables of India are sinking and the same
damn thing is going to occur with a bad
drought and this the Gandhi from India
was telling that story and she said it
is a dangerous tragic condition so this
glowing economic machine that both China
and India has a tough deal with nature
and sooner or later the cards are going
to be played I think well you got a
double whammy in both of them because a
whole lot of trying a whole lot of India
rely on their water coming from the
snows and glaciers in the Himalayas yeah
those are drying up and so those rivers
that they got used same as losing the
snowpack here in California only Hugh
to scale so the combination of already
taking the aquifers down and having less
water coming of the mountains
I think that's Jordan you ought to do
this mm-hmm
you should sponsor a conference and
bring over representatives of for
industrial mites that are in the same
tragic condition California's in those
regards water and drought China India
Australia and sit down with California
and a lot of Averell government Africa
and talk about what we need to do
whatever one of us does we all should do
and way of improved management
Australians wheat crop fails last year
the Murray River home of the platypus
and so on this is a very serious time in
a very serious condition in the world
and we naively fiddle along for a year
debating some of our political points
nonsensically in my view instead of
dealing with it well it's interesting
because California that Steinbeck wrote
about it has this cycle of dry years and
wet years and you have that the memory
is never quite long enough during the
wet years to remember the guy years are
gonna come again we're the situation's
we're looking at when climate changes
dry years that don't go away yeah and
those are the civilization killers
you'll get knocked down and get knocked
down a few times and then if the water
doesn't come back you don't get up trees
all died and you're in trouble on that
happy note let's call it an evening
thank you for coming thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]